pictures up
after we finished the infinity saga
we had a number of ideas for phase four
and where we wanted to go and there was
one filmmaker that could bring that to
the screen
the humanity and the scale and the epic
nature of that it's academy award winner
chloe jacques
i came in both as a filmmaker who wants
to tell story but also as a fan so my
vision for the film is how can we
capture something so epic and intimate
at the same time
and how to have these moments coexist in
the film and that was the challenge
but also was very exciting about it
that's cool
there's layers to this movie there's a
great sci-fi adventure
there's a very complex family drama let
them go you're gonna have to meet me
and we get to learn that these eternals
has been helping us to shape our history
and who we are and we also shape who
they are as well when you love something
you fight for it
she is a visionary and she takes this
movie at heart
[Music]
this is a huge movie it's huge in the
effects and the new world creation
chloe really wanted to use as much
practical sets as we could you want to
see the character in relationship to the
world behind them this is cersei
standing in front of babylon this is
kingo in the amazon it's definitely
going to give the film a different kind
of feel when you see those landscapes
we wanted to make sure the details are
in there for the big screen
power to design everything
you get transported onto this ipad
journey
[Music]
look where we are
[Music]
icarus
evening ladies
watch out
[Music]
who is it
[Music]
sorry